Applying forcefully, the one at the top is quick and
easy to make by fiddling with already-adopted animals The body should be strong, so let's see if it's a
gori or
something, let's make it huge for
now  It's not particularly thick. If
you double your height, you can't help but
feel bitter about the volume.  The
larger the
animal, the greater the amount of heat in its body, making it more resistant to the cold.
If you don't improve it, if you increase the area that comes into contact with the air, it will become easier to cool off.
I'm not particular about making everything smooth Hey,
let's leave at least Antz's share.
Let's give it to you Let's
hold on to the thorns and be strong
8th city Kaseda has been established
Gugu I feel bad for the
manufacturer It's the
end of the
season I fell down again I made a promise I broke my leg If I
double my height I'm eight times as heavy I'm lacking strength Make
my legs thicker  Try walking on all fours
Even after standing, I still feel like I'm worried about heat stroke
.
If you can't stretch your thighs, then stretch your flowers
me
[applause]